how's it goin man my name is pirata
it's been far too long since I play this
far too long I do apologize I've just
been busy flying flying hipster bowls
with dicks in my head I don't even know
how that ended up there it's dropping in
slow motion bouncing away sounds like
the end of a movie or some [ __ ] like
that
a porno probably what the [ __ ] am I
talking about
anyway we are at this new place
alright now it's working better what
what what waking my penis time alright
don't be distracted by the penis just
keep your focus we hunted a flying
Buffalo with these use an adjective to
give our arrows greater strength those
are not arrows oh there would be the
rarest all right great your strength
dragon iris they are daring that work no
Buffalo it became cheese whoa it's doing
flips and [ __ ] now oh well I guess that
was that huh sad story about Buffalo sad
story indeed hello friend what can I
help you with a bandit stole my money
help me get it back okay
now let me find a way to safely play
with my pet
let's put harmless hey sorry my pet
scorpion it's beautiful oh [ __ ] it's
growing bigger I don't like where this
is going I'm outta here
she's riding a scorpion I'm jelly those
buttered toast gang is on the loose
catch the criminals in return they're
Sheriff
[Music]
best dance ever
nice moustache bruh catch all crooks
know this great Gary gold digger from
its hiding spot return him to the
sheriff help me catch all the crooks
very greedy Gary gold trigger from his
hiding spot and I was hiding in that
rock
what is greedy Gary want dick he wants
money nah
tricked you [ __ ] okay who's next
that's one bandit down Kenny can't hold
it where is he where is he oh yes what
the [ __ ] is he doing I need to ride on
my okay I'm riding on a waterfall can't
believe it that looks like a cowboy hat
can't believe I never thought about this
before
alright Kenny can't hold himself that's
gotta be him shouldn't the waterfall
actually help for that knot I think
about it
ah I got a hint
show me the hint maybe he's having I
know he is hiding there sorry what to
follow just not holding it I don't know
Philip I know something about the
situation Peter bye
why does fit by the way okay it really
needs toilet paper I like that fine
toilet paper dirty toilet paper that's
what you get oh absolutely scut sting
only one Bennett left hat thief Hannah
okay so rainbow hakka rainbow flying
fast and ride a ball hockey oh my god
you're beautiful man I [ __ ] love this
thing by the way
alright what's what's the problem here
Hawk is excited about this look at that
[ __ ] alright hat get the [ __ ] outta way
all right what about the badass hat a
brass hat he's kind of steal it Hawking
knows something
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] PewDiePie is
hungry yeah that crazy son of a [ __ ] oh
my god we got a Hey look what we got
pocket go down there beauty pi/8 hog
yeah stop eating hockey I got a star
right there so it's ok son of a [ __ ]
that keeps eating hockey god dammit how
could you
I'm gonna ride this [ __ ] I'm out of
here whoa it's fuss what what happened
to him alright what's going on here
what's going on with this woman same
rare that's someone who can same in
Superman super car ok let's say let's
pull it
Scorpio what are you doing can I click
it No
[Music]
whoa how did I even do that Oh gotta get
it dead a dead I can't think whatever my
I'm Horace got sick and now I'm sucking
my poor horse let's summon abra kadabra
why not
you are welcome back I don't want the
Astra let's give him some medicine
that's not how you spell it
whatever hey get your [ __ ] hordes oh
he took it all right
my work is done here he shoved it up his
butt hello friend coax the snake out of
mineshaft shockwatch blows dildo go
dildo
oh [ __ ] watch out it's gonna blow Oh No
Oh can't be cheap girls I'll shed the
dildo exploded ahhh stop ahhh no [ __ ] my
scorpion poor scorpion alright what
happened here
I need to fly back to base well how
about a roflcopter they're welcome
coaxes they got in my in second a mouse
yes a dead I'm a genius I'm a
[ __ ] genius with an afro sorry
alright what do you want I'm hungry but
everything around here is alive how
about a zombie yeah no oh yay ten
holy [ __ ] bad has gone what alright I
got this one left and then that one
thing I don't even know what that it Oh
what the [ __ ]
okay interact
that was [ __ ] easy up and sessom oh
now I can go down there awesome my
friends what do you need well when a
bandit stole my money help you get it
back okay all this empty house easy
sorry hi oh boy oh no no oh it's time
for Marion bagans super huge dildo
rocket blood sorry
rocket launcher whoa
Oh what's up a tank go what's up Oh
what's up oh you don't [ __ ] with me
[ __ ] attack tag commander
Maxwell was defeated [ __ ] you [ __ ]
noob stop attack
whoa.good okay
remove [ __ ] I need another weapon
Samuel I sawed all right attack
Oh assassination [ __ ] give me
that money
why am I even helping and why alright
take this
[Music]
did I do it I think I did it you can now
play as Maxwell's brother tell me I got
all of them never complain
thank you thank you thank you so much
yes yes all right cool that means we
have not yet unlocked in the area though
we need 40 and I got 35 should be too
difficult metaphoric teleportation there
Dada Dada Dada Dada what's going on here
what in the fudge I love the music in
this game it's like yeah
I should not try to sing anyway I'm
doing it it sounds like something else
doesn't it sorry Greg Manor
why not when I've been here already yeah
I finish this place am i doing here you
know out of here
shut up zombies I got this song again
awesome
sorry I forgot okay
my job is to cut down this tree but I
don't have any toes how about a
woodcutter the axe
I wouldn't acts just like Minecraft do
it
just doing my job oh look at that guy
gay as [ __ ] what does he want nothing
wrong with being gay bro
I love gay people they're all so happy I
think I found a sasquatch den but to
have no way to document it how about a
video camera you're welcome
[Music]
that's not very nice poor sasquatch now
the Sasquatch is sad not [ __ ] no one
gives a [ __ ] about him let's be honest
you didn't care all right dog it's what
do you want I I could raise a human cup
this is Mowgli tiny black baby yes that
is how the story goes it's not racist
that's how it is
seriously don't question the story okay
help us finish this treehouse
construction er constructed there whoa
what the [ __ ] my contractor but that was
he called
yes what the hell it's this no no it's
mine it's mine it's mine it's mine
don't touch him here's my no no I need
to do it now stop stop let me click on
it all right add additives oh my god
let's ride Christ red cooker look at
this [ __ ] look at this [ __ ] it's
sniffing like he's eating people he
doesn't even give a [ __ ] my god this is
the best game ever
I will now fly away like in the black
baby no one gives a [ __ ] about him no
nothing so you're the one who's racist
you don't even remember about him all
right what are we doing all right
and this tree needs my help pollute
pollinate the fruit tree what how about
an apple how about B yeah flower center
fruit pitcher this kite is probably
someone it's probably his oh my god I
have a kite [ __ ] you it's mine
hahaha that's my awesome kite this kite
is the best kite ever
alright cause I got a Chinese episode
here like a third of you died
subscribe comment today and you know the
drill stay awesome and I'll see you
tomorrow say awesome I said it twice
because
[Music]
first I get chapeau now I get to do this
tastes like tomato sauce mixed with
tastes pretty good
give it up
[Music]